bonsoir monsieur françois mitterrand
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous quand
nous vous avions invité avant les
vacances pour cette émission de cartes
sur table de la rentrée nous pensions
que le sommet de la gauche serait
achevée en fait nous en sommes donc au
beau milieu nous sommes reconnaissantes
de d'inaugurer en quelque sorte avec
nous un genre de suspension de séance
plutôt exceptionnelle compte tenu de
l'actualité avec alain duhamel
nous allons vous interroger beaucoup sur
le sommet de la gauche sur vos rapports
avec le parti communiste sur les
perspectives de la gauche en cas de
victoire mais comme vous le souhaitez
comme c'est d'ailleurs logique nous vous
interrogions aussi sur les problèmes de
la majorité actuelle ou sur votre façon
de juger la situation politique et
économique d'aujourd'hui tout de suite
dans l'actualité en enchaînant sur ce
que le journal d'antenne 2 disais tout à
l'heure
monsieur georges marchais s'est donc
montré inquiet après la négociation de
cet après midi il disait qu'il était
impossible d'expliquer ce soir si la
négociation pouvait aboutir
ils l'estiment bloqué et il attend de
vous ce soir demain peut-être une
proposition une initiative mais je pense
comme lui et j'attends la même chose et
ça peut durer longtemps
non parce que nous sommes des hommes
responsables nous représentants des
partis politiques qui ont une grande
importance dans le pays nous avons pour
devoir de défendre les intérêts de
millions et de millions de français
il faudra bien en effet savoir
exactement il plus tôt possible
nous en sommes en rien une question qui
te au centre des négociations c'est ce
qui concerne les nationalisations et
notamment le nombre des filiales là
dessus dans sa conférence de presse ce
soir après votre séance de négociations
georges marchais a répété que le parti
socialiste que ses partenaires étaient
nettement en retrait par rapport à 1972
à votre avis je comprends pas ce que ça
veut dire ça fait partie des expressions
toutes faites agressive inutilement
agressif qu'on emploie contre parti
socialiste déjà depuis plusieurs mois on
est là pour s'expliquer et pour
s'expliquer devant beaucoup de français
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise de plus simple que ce que je vais
dire neuf groupes industriels ont été
prévus dans le programme commun signé en
1979 aux pâtisseries connaissez ces
biens neufs
c'est un plus
les barques d'ailleurs à cet égard
partis communistes et radicaux de gauche
souhaiterait qu'ils aient certaines
banques les petites qui sont pas
nationalisées voyez qu'ils sont a peur
que le jeu soit neuf groupes industriels
et bien moi je dis tout simplement
nationalisons tout ce qui appartient à
ces nouveaux tout tous les actifs tout
est ce que je peux dire de plus ce qui
fait de regarder
bien entendu cela veut dire il faut pas
nationaliser ce qu'ils n'ont pas parce
que si on nationalise qu'ils n'ont pas
c'est comme on nationalise le bien des
autres et les autres ils sont pas un
programme commun c'est à dire que dans
ce cas là il y aurait des actionnaires
très nombreux qui a le rouge parle
n'aurait pas su depuis cinq ans quel
sort leur réserve et on les prendre par
surprise
n'hésitez pas un programme commun 1969
sans quoi ça y serait voilà pourquoi la
position du parti socialiste est celle
ci le nombre des swaps et les filiales
on verra bien nous en avons nous à peu
près relevé une centaine mais c'est
encore plus simple si georges marchais
s'inquiète je lui réponds ici tout
simplement tout ce qui appartient aux 9
euros prévus par le programme commun
1972 tout doit être nationalisées mais
rien de ce qu'ils ne possèdent pas sans
quoi on nationalise pour l'autre chose
c'est un deuxième programme commun il
faut le dire comment se fait il alors
que sur le prime de ses filiales les
communistes en soi à 729 et que vous
disiez il serait ce parce qu'il raisonne
pas comme nous c'est parce que ils ont
établi une liste arbitraire une liste
comme ça laquelle céder 51 celles des
sociétés filiales des groupes
est ce qu'on appelle on va appeler les
pauses bien sûr comprendre des sociétés
mères le principal palais les groupes
qui détiennent toutes ses filiales
ils disent on commence à partir 51% on
pourrait dire autre chose
nous nous disons il faut nationaliser
donc donné à la puissance publique
expropriés contraint domination
naturellement tout ce qui appartient aux
neuf groupes industriels
la décision étant prise on va en voir
les conséquences
permettez que je fasse quelques
distinctions
quand la société mère principal on va
dire p chine et je pourrais dire rhône
poulenc
lorsqu elle possède 100% d'une autre
société pour être plus exact mais on va
entrer dans des finesses c'est en
réalité 98 à 80,18 et demi pour cent
parce que la loi veut que les personnes
qui sont membres des conseils
d'administration et la possession de
quelques actions si bien que personne ne
possède vraiment 100% mais sans vie en
main donc dans toutes les sociétés
détenues à 100% 98% par les sociétés
mères elles sont nationalisées elles
deviennent des sociétés nationales
là où elle ne possède que 75% à bien ont
nationalisé 75% c'est à dire que les 75%
deviennent la propriété de la
collectivité nationale avec
indemnisation des actionnaires mais on
ne nationalisent pas les 25% qui
appartiennent à d'autres groupes qui ne
sont pas dans le programme coml 1962
alors je voudrais pas que l'explication
apparaissent comme trop compliquée
j'espère que tout le monde
la comprend je ne peux rien dire plus
tout mais vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
dans la négociation et apparemment ça
pas convaincu le parti comment il faut
toujours un peu de temps pour ça pensez
que vous finirez par leur faire accepter
cette idée le bon sens finit toujours
par triompher lors ce que les français
arriveront peut-être mal à comprendre
c'est comment au bout de tant d'années
d'alliance vous posez simplement le
problème maintenant vous êtes allé dans
d'autres émissions que bâche se pose la
même question comment s'est-il qu'avec
un programme commun qui est parfaitement
honnête et au clair depuis le mois de
juin 1972 comment sait-il que le parti
communiste découvert depuis trois mois
qu'elle est quelque chose qui valait à
des lectures différentes du bruit en
commun ou alors d'autres dans toutes les
invitations dans to text et dans tout
contrat et parfaitement licite
parfaitement permis que chacun dise moi
c'est comme ça je comprends mais au bout
d'un certain temps ça suffit ça suffit
je pense que ça fait comme vous le
disiez fort bien assez longtemps que le
programme commun étaient proposés tous
les français il est est proposée au
moment des élections législatives de
on allait on a élu les députés n'a
dessus à l'élection présidentielle de
1974 aux élections cantonales de 1976
aux élections municipales de cette année
977 programme commun ils étaient très
bien la preuve c'est que entre 1973 et
nous avons constamment monte dans le
pays au public pourquoi est-ce qu'ils le
découvrent maintenant vos partenaires il
y à moi je ne vais pas juger les gens
je pense qu'il y a un aspect tactique
dans tout cela je n'élimine pas
l'hypothèse que nos partenaires auraient
pu éprouver quelques inquiétudes devant
la progression de développement du parti
socialiste actuel oui sans doute mais je
ne leur je ne veux pas leur retirer
aussi les raisons qui pourraient être
tout simplement en tant que parti
communiste ils ont une autre idée
elles seront autant de parties communes
après tout en 1972 il aurait voulu que
le parc le programme commun soit déjà
autre chose c'est nous qui n'avons pas
voulu mon truc c'était très bien comme
ça que c'était mettre en mesure le
gouvernement de l'union de la gauche les
partis qui sont du lion de l'union à
gauche étant représentés tous au
gouvernement de faire de comment
dirais-je de la bonne politique pour la
france il faut quand même que vous
imaginez que nous n'aurons pas une
succession facile
nous sommes dans une très grave crise on
vient de battre le record du chômage
là où j'ai pris ça continue le déficit
du commerce extérieur du commerce
extérieur aussi on vient de constater
que la croissance n'avait été que de 3 %
alors qu'on avait annoncé catherine mais
pour ça ce serait mieux si vous êtes
décision que les choses étaient claires
donc cgt va vous dire
donc c'est une situation difficile il
faut avoir le sens des responsabilités
on peut pas promettre n'importe quoi il
faut tenir ce que l'on promet et de ce
point de vue le programme commun que
nous socialistes nous voulons respecter
intégralement tous les programmes comme
le répète ça nous paraît le meilleur
instrument alors nous trouvons un peu
dommage que on est créé une situation
politique pour la gauche plus difficile
en posant des exigences excessives
après tout l'actualisation qu'est ce que
c'était la monnaie le franc
malheureusement a perdu de sa valeur
depuis cinq ans les prix ont continué de
monter le chômage s'est accru le pouvoir
d'achat un finalement diminué par
rapport à ses valeurs profondes
notamment le speak
à partir de là il fallait actualisée
c'est à dire remettre au niveau de 1977
ce qui avait été prévu en 1972 et puis
il y avait peut-être des problèmes
nouveaux qui se pose est naturellement
il s'impose en cinq ans de fouilles y
répondre et puis à des problèmes qui
étaient actuelle en 1972 et qui ne sont
plus aujourd'hui la reconnaissance de la
république du vietnam la reconnaissance
de l'allemagne devrait revenir à 7 puis
appel mais sortir de cet horizon là pour
négocier un deuxième programme commun
avant d'avoir appliqué le premier est
bien non est-ce que vous n'allez pas
vous faire dire de la part de nos
partenaires que vous voulez en quelque
sorte imposé la volonté du parti de ces
listes sur le parti communiste comme ça
a été dit est certainement parmi eux
mende avec les reproches que s'arrêter
et ça va entraîner le goûter est ce que
vous n'avez pas l'impression au moins
depuis le début du mois d'août est ce
que le parti communiste pas donner un
peu l'impression de vouloir à tout prix
imposer ses volontés à après tout c il a
des grandes qualités le parti communiste
et les militants communistes sont des
gens sérieux mais c'est sont organisées
à troupes de choc et c'est tous les
jours moi je peux pas me réveiller
coucher passer ma journée déjeuner dîner
il ya toujours quelque chose à la radio
et télé qui m'apprend des exigences
nouvelles
forcément il faut me laisser me
reprendre mon souffle et d'en dire aux
français soyons plus raisonnable que ça
on a un bon contrat respectons de
garneau le proposons le français et
allons aux élections avec cela d'autant
plus qu'à la veille de ce débat qui est
un débat utile mais dans le la façon
dont on le développement n'a pas
toujours été très heureux
tout le monde savait ont considéré comme
acquis la victoire de la gauche donc
tout ce qui compromet cette victoire
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne devrait pas
faire alors justement est-ce que
vous pouvez en quelque sorte vous offrir
une crise est-ce que vous pouvez vous
offrir une discussion qui traîne l
histoire
moi je veux offrir si vous c'est ce que
la gauche électoralement je ne le
souhaite pas le parti socialiste n'a pas
du tout de demander d'ajouter quoi que
ce soit aux programmes cobol ou alors on
est dans une situation bloquée comme
sérieux les jeunes réunionnais
souhaitent qu'on aboutisse et le parti
socialiste fera tout ce qu'il devra
faire pourra voter
nous n'avons pas fermé la porte à un
certain nombre de propositions
importants de la négociation la durée
nous a même reproché au cours des
événements de la semaine dernière à nous
socialistes de ne pas avoir claqué la
porte tout de suite mais problème vous
savez c'est un problème que nous devons
obtenir avec le plus grand sérieux
le parti socialiste et moi même je peux
le dire sans exagérer mon rôle nous
sommes quand même garant de l'union de
la gauche
les autres naturellement l'ont fait avec
nous quand on se marie c'est au moins
deux là on était trois encore 3 le plus
radicaux de gauche et sont venus un peu
plus tard comme ça c'est à dire ainsi le
permettez moi de vous dire que le sens
de non pas dans un autre domaine le les
radicaux de gauche sont venus signer le
programme commun après coup c'est à dire
que ils sont acceptés ce qu'ils avaient
dans la fameuse petite phrase sur la
nationalisation la garde malgré tout ils
ont accepté
bon alors non mais c'est ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que le contrat c'est
un contrat je ne dénie absolument pas
aux au parti communiste le droit le
pouvoir de débattre d'ouvrir la
discussion
nous les connaissons bien et nous aimons
bien disputer mais le parti socialiste
se considèrent particulièrement comme le
garant de l'union de la gauche comme le
garant de la victoire et après la
victoire le garant de la réussite
donc on ne peut pas faire n'importe quoi
alors justement ce qui concerne la
petite phrase d'en évoquer à l'instant
bon il faut il faut rappeler en un mot
qu'il s'agit de ce qu'on appelle
simplement les nationalisations à la
carte alors vous aviez proposé la
semaine dernière une solution à vos
partenaires qui consistait en faisant
allusion au préambule la cantine en 1946
dans limite à t on l'espère rezai vous
raconter comment cela s'est passé à côté
d'autant mieux le faire j'ai déjà lu
dans les journaux sans quoi je ne ferai
pas ça moi je ne suis pas indiscret
lorsqu'on nous demande d'être lent mais
vous avez des avis qui savent raconter
les et j'espère que non s'il le faut
alors se sont pas avérées amis il faut
respecter les engagements qu'on prend
bon alors comment ça se passe avec les
radicaux de gauche robert fabre demande
que l'ombre que l'on supprime du
programme commun de phrases qui porte
justement sur le sujet que vous venez
d'évoquer pour que tout le monde voit
clair c'est à dire que les possibilités
pour les travailleurs de demander la
nationalisation de leurs entreprises
étant entendu qu'une fois que ils l'ont
demandé c'est le gouvernement qui devant
le parlement peut trancher à faire la
demande ne se transforme pas en accord
aux femmes
c'est comme ça que les choses soient
élus radicaux de gauche ils en ont bien
le droit nous ont demandé de supprimer
les deux phrases qui aboutissent à ce
résultat
discuter là dessus sans je marche est
dit mais je n'arrête pas de préciser
c'est vrai je n'arrête pas de préciser
que la constitution le dit aussi
tu prend exactement ça comme ça la
constitution de 1958 celle qui nous
régit actuellement a repris à son compte
ce peu compliqué le préambule de la
constitution de 1946 et dans le
préambule de 1946 qui est donc
actuellement constitutionnel puisque ça
a été repris par 1958 il y a la
possibilité et je dirais presque de voir
que chaque fois qu'une entreprise
supprime la libre concurrence devient
monopolistique ou de 10 on devient en
fait un service public il faut
nationaliser et que l'on n'a le droit de
le demander georges marchais rappel cela
et il avait tout à fait raison
alors je dis l'idée m'est venue comme
cela je ne me posais pas en arbitres
disons que j'ai essayé d'arranger les
choses comme le parti socialiste s'est
constamment dans la limite naturellement
des intérêts nationaux et les intérêts
de la gauche alors je dis bon bien il
mettre cette référence constitutionnelle
comme ça on sera exactement de quoi on
parle monsieur fable bien entraînés et
l'a entendu mais est il à ce que je
suppose entendu les buts exprimé à voir
pour dire normal mais il n'a pas semblé
le remarquer bon alors là dessus pas
exactement là dessus sur l'ensemble des
problèmes des nationalisations
après que le parti socialiste est et
expliquer ses positions et ses reçu mon
père fabre que je connais bien mais que
cachent des relations amicales et je
connais ses mérites
c'est pas facile de diriger une
organisation politique mais je ne sais
moi aussi mais malgré tout on leur fait
bondir il est parti et puis il est
revenu
et puis les problèmes sont restés ça va
bien vous appréciez vous apprécié assez
sévèrement l'esclandre de l'autre jour
c'est ça qui s'apprêtait une dimension
je n'apprécierais pas moi je pensais que
s'il le fallait prendre des dispositions
sur cette affaire version de constater
que que que l'accord n'était pas
possible c'est à dire que nos
partenaires ne faisait pas les
concessions que nous jugeons nécessaire
mais je pensais qu'il fallait aller au
moins gros bout de l'examen du programme
commun il n'a pas vu sérieux n'a pas
obligé à modifier votre propre tactique
avons continué cet après midi il semble
que georges marchais cents soit plane ou
socialiste de maintenir exactement les
propositions que nous avions faites la
semaine dernière lorsque monsieur robert
favreau fonds la semaine dernière en
refusant ce qu'il appelle collectivisme
le capitalisme d'état la bureaucratie
n'a pas exprimé aussi un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes du parti socialiste s'il
s'agissait de collectivisme de
capitalisme d'état et robert femme
n'aurait fait que reprendre et il aurait
bien fait ce que j'ai moi même écrit
précédemment
mais bien entendu je ne lui attribue pas
le fait d'avoir répéter mes propos les
radicaux de gauche sont par nature
politique des libéraux qui acceptent
d'ailleurs avec courage car ce n'est pas
toujours facile je le répète les
perspectives socialiste puisqu'ils sont
les alliés de deux grands partis qui se
réclament chacun sa manière du
socialiste mais mais mais mais cela dit
donc c'est une position qui lui est
propre
il est sincère mais lorsqu il le dénonce
le collectivisme sous la forme
caporalise bureaucratie étatisme alors
alors ils rentrent exactement d'en
visiter car je pense qu'une expérience
de gauche échoué et ne devrait pas avoir
lieu si elle ne devait pas d'abord
libérer les français des contraintes qui
pèsent qui pèse exagérément sur
actuellement donc la semaine dernière il
a vous avez ouvert la porte qu'il a
claqué viennent si on veut une image
anadyomène oui un nouvel la cloque et
oui la semaine dernière parce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est un homme de de
bonvouloir fait je crois que j'ai
l'impression très nette de l'avoir
rencontré cet après-midi alors toujours
sans cette phrase de vous mettre
d'accord sur les bases dont vous parliez
votre avis mais je ne sais pas je n'ai
pas ici que je vais régler et la
discussion qui réunit depuis cet après
midi qui reprendra demain matin la
discussion qui réunit 30 personnes c'est
à dire 10 socialistes des communistes et
des radicaux de gauche c'est pas avec
vous je vais arriver ça non mais les
premiers jeux mais je suis tout prêt à
vous informer que je suis là pour ça
maintenant ce qu'on sait moins les
questions poser moins de questions par
exemple au delà des nationalisations il
ya aussi des problèmes ou des phrases
dont on ne parle pas nous avons relu
attentivement une nouvelle fois le
programme commun nous allons finir par
connaître par coeur le chapiteau 3 nous
avons lu que le plan par exemple
allez on pouvait encadré garantir le
fonctionnement du secteur privé il en
déterminera les grands investissements
ainsi que leur mode de financement
est ce que ça veut pas dire que par ce
biais l'état peut aussi continuer le
contrôler et de récompenser en quelque
sorte les bons et les mauvais chefs
d'entreprise que ce que qu'est ce que ça
veut dire le plan ci se veut pas dire ça
les sociétés qui se réclament du
libéralisme économique d'une société
désuète
on est passés ont horreur des plans
parce qu'un plan ça peut empêcher le
grand capitalisme de faire ce qu'il veut
le pouvoir politique s'impose au pouvoir
économique
un plan c fait justement pour ça donc
je vois pas quelle autre définition je
pourrais donner si le plan veut se
substituer comme ça s'est produit par
exemple en russie soviétique un plan
qu'on appelle macroéconomique un plan
géant qui se substitue à toutes les
initiatives locales régions communes
individus aller dans une
collectivisation qui est intégral c'est
le type de société dont nous ne voulons
pas dont nous ne voulons pas naturel
marc font partie du même si nous avons
nous juristes
même si nous avons plus grand respect et
de l'amitié pour le pays dans lequel
salir ou cette expérience je veux dire
la russie bon alors que dans d'autres
pays comme la yougoslavie
le plan est très décentralisée ont dit
auto heureuse à moitié vrai ou car le
vrai je sais pas exactement neuf en tout
cas on a laissé toute une série de
petites unités aux moyennes unités
déterminer elle-même leur leur stratégie
industrielle prévue là ça lui remettre
un peu d'ordre dans tout cela est
planifié car on se trouvait dans une
situation de extrêmement fâché sur le
plan d'économies le plan ça veut dire ça
ça veut dire ne pas se substituer à tout
le monde m'est donné de grands lits
est-ce qu'il faut donner un coup de main
à l'agriculture ou est-ce qu'il faut
donner à l'industrie
est-ce qu'il faut donner aux textiles ou
à la métallurgie à la sidérurgie ou à la
chimie est-ce qu'il faut donner dans
l'agriculture au blé ou à la viande
l'occasion aux deux à la fois choisir on
est des gens comment dire l homme et l
animal intelligent qu'il use de
l'intelligence qu'il prévoit qu'il
consulte qu'il qu'il écoute les gens qui
travaillent les nos questions sur le
tard ils ont quelque chose à dire on ne
peut pas quand même vivre comme
aujourd'hui dans cet état ou une
administration d'autorité et quelques
ministres qui souvent se moque du monde
croit pouvoir diriger les faits la
france sans jamais se couper les
français alors puisque vous disiez vous
pouviez nous donner des informations il
ya deux autres points sont les derniers
masques rêve et on a bon dos pour ça je
le répète il ya deux autres points qui
sont importants dans les discussions
actuelles et qui touche l'une au secteur
social l'autre à la défense nationale et
à la force de frappe ou non le bien
d'autrui non non non on ne peut pas tout
faire traiter de tout
considérée souvent comme l'essentiel
alors il ya un point précis c'est la
question de savoir si le sommet de la
gauche acceptera ou n'acceptera pas de
fixer un éventail des revenus alors
parti communiste était pour les radicaux
de gauche et vous vous étiez contre est
ce que tu es alors non non moi je suis
pour le programme commun bien sûr bon
ben vous l'avez lu oui bon il parle pas
de durée serment de l'éventail bruit
laissant chif
voilà mais il annule tout l'effort de ce
gouvernement tendra à réduire le
scandaleux éventail des revenus et aussi
des salaires et qui sait que la france
est aujourd'hui un pays plus injuste
plus inégal du plus petit le plus grand
que les états unis d'amérique ou que
l'allemagne de l'ouest vous imaginez
alors bon alors qu'il faut resserrer
pour resserrer il faut d'abord élever
les plus petits bon tu es ensuite il
faut par toute une série de procédés et
l'impôt sur le revenu après tout il fait
pour ça une info sur les sociétés enfin
la fiscalité fait pour ça il faut
arriver à ramener dans des limites
raisonnables mais vraiment prétendre
qu'il serait possible et même qu'il
serait souhaitable
je ne pense pas que cela soit
souhaitable de resserrer de 1 à 5
comme nous l'a demandé le parti
communiste l'éventail des salaires alors
qu'il faudrait s'attaquer aux revenus ou
6 1 et que aussi ça regarde les
syndicats sans regarder concerne les
conventions collectives
là on substitue l'état aux draps aux
travailleurs et à leurs représentants
naturel même laisser les partenaires
sociaux discuter ensemble de 1 à 5
ce n'est pas réalisable cela n'a été
réalisée nulle part au monde même dans
des régimes qu'ils ont prétendu et qui
sont en place les uns depuis 60 ans les
eaux depuis 40 ans prétendent que c'est
possible en cinq ans dans un pays comme
la france se dit non et j'ajoute que ce
n'est pas souhaitable
alors si ce n'est pas possible c'est
donc démagogique et si c'est parce que
t'as foutu faut discuter
soyons raisonnables il faut réduire
l'éventail des revenus et l'éventail des
salaires dans des proportions qui dans
l'état actuel des choses aurait beaucoup
de peine à atteindre les 1 7 et même les
proposé par la cfdt alors puisque vous
êtes en désaccord sur ces points nous
disons oui non mais comment vous allez
faire pour en sortir
on peut en sortir que par le sang se
disent ont de l'intérêt général
je suis convaincu que les communistes
sont des gens très très soucieux de
l'intérêt général
ils ont comme nous leur préférence leur
choix quelquefois leur passion leur
volonté de certaines ont fait ce qu'ils
estiment être la vérité leur vérité au
nous aussi après tout mais à partir d'un
certain degré lorsqu'on ne s'explique je
suis convaincu que les communistes
n'irons pas plus loin qu'il le faut
pourquoi seraient ils les seuls en
france à proposer leur serment d'un
éventail de un sac que nous refuserons
alors je suis venu dire nous irons
jusqu'au bout s'il le fallait
alors que la cfdt demande un peu plus et
que la cgt ne demande pas du tout et que
le parti communiste lui même l'année
dernière encore je crois estimé que
c'était une mauvaise forme alors il
reste un dernier point c'est ce qui
concerne la force de frappe
bon là le programme commun vous ne
corrigera si je me trompe le programme
commun avait prévu que en gros ont l'âge
les bons le parti communiste on se le
rappelle a changé de position sur cette
question
et manifestement vous n'êtes pas tout à
fait d'accord avec sa position vous avez
évoqué la possibilité si un gouvernement
de gauche de faire un référendum sur
l'ensemble des questions nucléaires soit
il aux soins et aux soyons honnêtes nous
avons parlé au pays depuis des années
communistes socialistes radicaux de
gauche et depuis des années nous avons
dit non à la bombe atomique mais on
expliquer pourquoi on le dit c'est
dangereux pour la sécurité du pays
c'est trop coûteux pour notre économie
c'est inutiles ou inefficaces et fils a
cessé quand même puisque nous étions
minoritaires
il faut tenir compte des réalités cela
fait maintenant 20 ans que notre
politique militaire est axée sur le
développement de l'armé nucléaire
ça veut pas dire que ce soit une bonne
solution mais pour l'instant notre armée
est organisée autour de cela à compter
du moment nous sommes des hommes
politiques dans le réel on est bien
obligé de tenir compte de ça même si on
déplore cette politique alors évidemment
à prendre tout d'un coup par simple
décision d'état major que la politique a
été changé du tout au tout que on disait
hier non à la bombe atomique
tout d'un coup il faut dire oui et nous
trouver 10 on ne reproche qu'on nous
adresse
du côté du parti communiste qu' il
faudrait dire tout de suite oui nous
aussi comme ça sans quoi on n'a pas dans
l'esprit le sens de l'un de
l'indépendance nationale ou les intérêts
nationaux
alors ça nous a un peu choqué alors on
examine les choses et le groupe de
travail qui a travaillé pendant les deux
mois à peu près ce que je veux en
juillet surtout le groupe de travail
était arrivé à des propositions très
correct en indiquant que de toute façon
la renonciation à la bombe atomique
était l'objectif du gouvernement de la
gauche en disant qu'il fallait tout de
suite s'attaquer à la capacité par une
conférence internationale la france
poser des problèmes aux pays détenteur
de la bombe
et si possible à tous les autres ensuite
on fait des propositions pour le
désarmement et on revient là où la
france est absente car elle est absente
actuellement en fait de tous les
endroits où l'on discute de désarmement
d'allemand et donc en fait de la paix et
puis on dit quand on connaîtra le
résultat de cette action diplomatique
en attendant nous aurons maintenu la
force nucléaire en état
on ne pas couler sous marins et nous
examinerons notre politique et nous
ajoutons nos socialistes position qui
n'est pas retenu par nos partenaires
nous ajoutons et nous consultons les
français d'où l'idée de référendum
moi je n'ai jamais posé le problème du
référendum en termes de dison de diktat
je pense que c'est une bonne idée vous
continuez à le penser
je continue de penser que c'était une
bonne idée je pense c'est pas parce que
c'est moi qui l'ait mais on le croit
qu'on est toujours un peu tendance à
trouver excédent de ces composites est
mauvais c'est ceci est un défaut
universel mais je pense que c'était une
bonne idée pourquoi parce que lorsqu on
ira aux élections législatives
c'est au mois de mars 78 tous les
problèmes seront posées parfois et on
votera de ce nom là sur l'état de la
situation économique
on votera droite on votre à gauche on
votera pour ce qui représente les forces
de progrès nous ou pour celle ce qui ce
qui représente les forces ou pouvoir les
autres maintenant tout pouvoir
on sera conservateur montserat comment
dirais-je des hommes d'avenir on ça les
électeurs feront ce qu'ils voudront mais
au milieu de cet énorme retrouvé
beaucoup de français qui ont une idée
sur l'armement nucléaire et sur le
nucléaire civil ne pouvons pas vraiment
saisir cette affaire là pour la
présenter dans sa réalité dans son
ampleur au français donc il se peut
mauvais qu'il y ait une grande
circonstances dans lesquelles le
gouvernement s'engage régulièrement
comme de gauche dire est ce qu'il pense
naturellement séduit pas laisser les
choses aller n'importe comment pense
qu'il est très important que le que les
français puissent dire leur mot c'est à
dire nos partenaires historiques comme
les communistes l'ont dit c'est donc les
français qui auront à expliquer au
gouvernement la politique qu'il doit
avoir et j'ai très bien compris
j'ai dit que le gouvernement
s'engagerait proposerait une solution
aux français au vu de la situation
internationale sur laquelle il aura
essayé de peser entre temps bon alors
que les françaises déterminerait très
bien je tiens à dire ici que je n'ai
jamais posé cette affaire du référendum
comme une condition sinequanone du parti
si les autres ne veulent pas on va pas
leur imposer simplement j'exprimerai mon
regret et le parti socialiste continuera
d'espérer qu'un jour nous partenaires se
rallieront à cette bonne idée j'ai
mitterrand paul laurent disais lors de
la fête de l'humanité que vous dites
souvent non non non et qu'au bout d'un
certain moment que oui après les
explications du parti communiste vous
dites oui oui oui
est ce qu'il ya des butoirs sur lesquels
vous ne transigerai pas est ce que vous
vous sonné j'ai quand même dit oui au
programme commun je vais signer je suis
heureux ceux qui l'ont signé
écoutez on va essayer d'élargir le débat
beaucoup d'autres femmes et hommes
politiques responsables ont été les bons
ouvriers de l'union de la gauche
je suis loin d'être le seul depuis des
gens connus jusqu'à des inconnus dans
tous nos villages qui ont créé le
courant populaire donc je ne m'attribue
pas se mérite
mais disons que l'histoire a voulu et la
bourgeoisie qu'à diverses reprises
depuis 12 13 ans je représente
au nom de tous l'union de la gauche
croyez vous qu à six mois des élections
ils peuvent permettre de réaliser ce qui
est plus qu'un rêve
ce qui est une volonté ce qu'ils aient
le sentiment profond de l'intérêt
national de l'intérêt des français il
faut que les français vivent mieux
il faut qu'ils vivent autrement est ce
que vous croyez que c'est à six mois du
but qui n'est pas un but d'ambition ou
alors cette ambition elle est immense
croyez vous que c'est à ce moment là on
va faire le contraire qui pourrait le
croire
quel français pourrait croire à
l'instant que moi même françois
mitterrand mais beaucoup plus que moi le
parti socialiste totalement possédé par
cette idée de l'union de la gauche n'est
pas la panne n'est pas la volonté autour
du programme commun de réussir jusqu'aux
médias le parti communiste avait rama
yade gagné quelque 30
lionel jospin qui est un de vos
lieutenants a écrit un article important
parlant de la stratégie du soupçon à
propos du parti communiste à l'égard du
procès peut-être les dirigeants kobe
steel
objectif leur soin particulier
je le répète parti communiste les
dirigeants communistes mais je voudrais
répondre à votre question je suis
convaincu qu'il y a des centaines de
milliers de vies en millions d'électeurs
communistes qui savent je dis la vérité
qui font confiance à ce que je dis pas
quand cette guerre aujourd'hui
maintenant qu'ils le savent qui sauf que
c'est toute ma conviction et
l'engagement de ma vie mais je dis qu
appliquer le programme commun et avant
d'avoir appliqué le programme commun qui
est déjà un immense effort nous l'avons
tous dit nos partenaires ont proposé le
programme commun avec quelle fois à côté
de nous partout sur toutes les tribunes
publiques sur les affiches sur les murs
ils ont dit comme nous le programme
commun c'est bien c'est bon il faut le
faire alors avant d'avoir appliqué le
programme commun en a pas on n'a pas
commencé nous sommes pas au gouvernement
freda faire autre chose ce n'est pas
responsable a expliqué c'est tout ce que
les expliquez nous pourquoi le parti
comme par exemple d'une certaine
formation d'un psychologue je sais pas
analyse - sociale or je sais pas moi en
tant qu'homme politique je pense que le
parti communiste à des essais d'un grand
parti qui est historique qui est inscrit
dans l'histoire de la france et dans
l'histoire du monde déjà depuis depuis
1920 en france mais disons dans le cadre
du mouvement communiste international
depuis 1917
c'est une grande affaire nous
socialistes cela fait également très
longtemps depuis 1920 que nous avons
considéré que nous ne pouvions pas nous
identifier au communisme nous n'étions
pas pour le système communiste que nous
refusions le système communiste avant de
se rejoindre pour faire l'union de la
gauche comme nous nous y sommes efforcés
au point d'y réussir et il a fallu
prendre la peine donc le parti
communiste a fait une large part du
chemin et il faut lui rendre justice
mais dans l'intervalle il s'est produit
quelque chose il s'est trouvé qu'une
parti socialiste qui depuis très
longtemps depuis 1936 avait baissé dans
l'opinion publique qui était devenu lui
est le deuxième parti de gauche et
d'assez loin que ce qu'on pouvait
représenter au moment d'epinay quand
nous avons fait notre unité
10 ou 11 % d'opinions publiques nous
représentons peut-être aujourd'hui 27 28
29 30% je ne sais pas c'est à dire que
nous sommes devenus les premiers non
seulement les premiers de la gauche mais
les premiers en france alors il est
normal que pour des communistes
dirigeant communiste responsable sincère
il croit dans ce qu'ils font qu'ils
éprouvent une sorte de saisissement ils
se demandent s'ils peuvent s'ils doivent
continuer une stratégie qui en fait a
consacré une un rapport de force pour
vous et c'est un souci légitime mais ce
souci légitime est quand même moins
légitime que celui qui doit faire
aboutir l'union de la gauche autour du
programme commun et quand vous voyez les
difficultés vous avez vu que en ce
moment justement alors que vous êtes
encore dans l'opposition mais vous voyez
les autres n'ont pas de difficultés est
ce que vous croyez qu'elle existe une
société où n'ai pas de difficulté dans
le moindre club sportif dans le moindre
mouvement il ya des difficultés
donc c'est banal mais c'est la
démocratie tu es démocratie vous avez
dit vous même que le temps c'est pas
banal non parce que l'enjeu
oui ravanal six mois dont je ne suis pas
banal l'enjeu est immense
l'enjeu est immense mais regardez ce qui
se passe dans la majorité la majorité 1
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait comment est-ce
que ça a commencé en 1974 monsieur
chaban delmas est candidat monsieur
giscard d'estaing aussi monsieur second
delmas est largement distancée dans son
échec est intervenu un événement
important c'est que l'un de ses
principaux soutiens
membres du même parti monsieur chirac
l'a abandonné en cours de route pour se
rallier aux concurrents d'un autre parti
monsieur giscard d'estaing ça a pesé
et puis monsieur giscard monsieur chirac
est devenu premier ministre
et puis comme si ça devenait chez lui
une sorte l'habitude il est vrai que
l'habitude commence à la première fois
et il a à son tour laissé tomber
monsieur giscard d'estaing c'est à dire
que il avait choisi monsieur giscard
d'estaing contribution seulement delmas
mais il a préféré chirac et giscard
d'estaing bien entendu alors
oui ça a pas laissé de traces layton
était moi de vous dire je suis restée
révélant ainsi parfaitement c'est la
démocratie
seulement la différence ce que nous nous
discutons d'idées et de projets tels que
ils discutent de personnes ils ont entre
les ambitions et les rivalités
nous on a aucune rivalité avec georges
marchais je dois dire même que c'est un
homme
bin hammam canon je pas dit ça même
quand je trouve un peu désagréable comme
ça la télévision parce que je regarde
aussi de temps en temps lorsque se
trouve il est agressif comme ça mais je
discerne chez lui une volonté une
sincérité
c'est un homme qui est totalement leurs
représentants de son parti et donc de
beaucoup de français ils y croient et de
ce point de vue ils méritent le respect
qu on va on n'a pas travaillé toutes ces
années sans avoir entre nous deux comme
ça des liens qui font que l'on peut se
parler quoi même quand ça dépasse
légèrement le temps enfin vous croyez
qu'avec ce genre d'arguments qui ont
amplement qui donc simplement écouter
mais ces positions du parti communiste
peut évoluer dans les négociations et
vous puissiez je pouvais comprendre la 6
et pour des parties de s'élever assez de
force de conviction pour que les
dirigeants communistes soit assuré que
le parti socialiste est un parti engagé
autant que dans la construction d'union
de la gauche dans la victoire et dans la
réussite après la victoire qu'il n'est
pas question pour nous mais qui se
permet de le supposer
il n'est pas question pour nous d'avoir
une autre perspective que de réussir
l'union de la gauche
si cette petite réunion ce soir avec
vous deux puis quelques autres ne me
permettaient de les en convaincre non
seulement sur le plan de la logique non
seulement sur le temps de la
responsabilité politique
moi aussi sur le plan dix ans de des
sentiments de ce centre de fraternité
qui se créent dans les combats on en a
fait assez ensemble et uniquement pour
lui le combat que comme tous les
français qu'ils m'entendent que nous
défendons une vérité profonde nous
voulons la réussite de l'union de la
gauche
alors si votre question avait servi à
cela je dis à jean le marché équipés
coûte peut-être à ce moment là et bien
revenons tout simplement
au programme commun
de 1972 à dire à venir le appliquons le
strictement totalement nationalisons les
neuf groupes industriels dans tous leurs
biens ne nationalisent ont pas ce qui ne
leur appartient pas restons fidèles aux
engagements alors à partir de là je
pense que s'il veut bien peu diminuer la
masse des demandes nouvelles qui ferait
de l'ancien programme un nouveau
programme je pense qu'on arrivera très
bien s'arranger
ce qui va pas dire que vous avez le
monopole de l'intérêt général je n'ai
pas dit cela si on va bien dégoûté c'est
sûr qu'il ya beaucoup de français qui
m'ont bien écouté il à aucun moment ils
n'ont pu tirer de mes propos l'idée que
j'avais voulu confisquer pour moi seul
et pour le parti socialiste le sens de
l'intérêt général
alors à partir du moment où justement
vous défendre il faut pas nous en
risquions non plus à partir du moment où
vous défendez des positions comme ça
avec constance un vous lui dites quand
quand le dirigeant communiste au fond
explique que les socialistes ont une
sorte de propension à la trahison
on trouve tant des articles avec des
exemples historiques
verigy lutte qu'est ce que vous voulez
je sais pas moi qui les ai inventées il
y a la première expérience communiste
dans le monde qui se réclame du
socialisme d'un certain socialiste qui
n'est pas le nôtre s'est installé dans
le dos l'un des plus grands pays du
monde en une union soviétique
enfin dans russie qui est devenue
l'union soviétique et autour d'une
doctrine séductrice et par le marxisme
c'est le marxisme-léninisme et il y
aurait là dessus beaucoup de choses a
dit ce marxisme-léninisme et est devenu
sorte de dogme c'est à dire à mon avis
un contre sens profond à faire que ça se
veut pas mêler les choses et dire
monopinion milieu de tout ça je raconte
l'histoire
mais avant la révolution léniniste tous
les socialistes ont presque tous étaient
sociaux démocrates
il s'appelait comme ça sociaux
démocrates
fredrik ingalls lamy le compagnon le coc
écrivain auteur le fondateur du
socialisme et du communisme mondial la
ville marx disait peu avant de mourir
que l'orgueil de sa vie ça vaut d'avoir
été de vivre et de mourir social
démocrate depuis sont des traîtres à dos
de la scission et de la rupture entre le
marxisme léninisme et notre socialisme
c'est à dire que ces mails et un
problème disons deux hommes se mêler
problème d'explication général de
l'histoire des hommes de l'histoire de
la société et comme toujours lorsque se
mêlent eu une opposition à l'opposition
politique
une position philosophique de caractère
mais dans certaines circonstances de
quasiment religieuse alors les passions
deviennent fives et vous savez bien
l'histoire du monde
le démontre on peut vivre et mourir pour
sa foi est ce qu'une brouille alors les
passions sont très vives mais si c'était
aussi vif
on est à notre égard qu'est-ce que je ne
le dirais alors sur le communisme et je
ne veux pas le dire sur ne pas que
certains disaient que c'était philinte
les misanthropes de moyens oui je suis
pas alceste je ne pense pas je dis la
vérité je cherche pas à dire toute la
vérité qui blesse
donc qu'est-ce que je ne dirais pas mais
je ne le dis pas parce que je ne veux
pas nuire à l'union de la gauche mais je
suis de torreilles des intéressés à bord
les oreilles des intéressés résonne de
ce que vous dites pas écouté et écouter
mais qui a été écrit déjà retrouvé
l'oeuvre de bloomer retrouver euros il
ya bien d'autres mais c'est parce que
c'est pas le sujet ce que je veux dire
c'est que nous sommes en effet dans deux
optiques de pensée différentes mais nous
représentons les mêmes couches sociales
mais justement je vais ses syndiqués
capitale
nous avions deux idées philosophiques
différentes mais nous représentons les
mêmes coût social et nous socialistes
comme je suis sur nous
nos camarades communistes nous nous
sommes dit la nécessité c'est de faire
passer avant nos propres dispute nos
propres explications différentes et même
opposé de l'histoire et de l'intérêt des
hommes dirigeants serbes précédemment
l'intérêt de ces travailleurs qui tant
que nous serons divisé seront exploitées
dominé gouverné par leurs adversaires de
classe mais au niveau du concret c'est
pas aussi facile mais annonce que vous
avez mais reconnaissez que depuis 1965
on a fait des progrès tout à fait on a
une candidature unique en 65 une
candidature unique en 74 des candidats
uniques à toutes les élections depuis 73
c'est pas mal la prochaine fois mais au
premier tour et c'est bien leur douar
présidentielle non mais c'est leur droit
l'essentiel c'est que la discipline de
la gauche joue au deuxième tour et fut
profondément comment vous pouvez vous
attaquer ensemble à transformer certains
jours on passe un peu j'ai encore deux
trois questions de procédure comment je
suis pas spécialiste de la querelle de
la gauche ah non mais vous sortez de 0,6
aciéristes et je suis responsable pour
lutter contre les forces conservatrices
qui à l'heure actuelle vouloir le pré
vous en aurez largement location vous
avez vous allez vous allez en parler
nous sommes en train de respecter le
temps que nous sommes fixés non mais
comment vous pouvez vous attaquez la
transformation de société actuels alors
que finalement vous n'êtes pas d'accord
sur le but final mais société final le
écoutez écoutez moi le produit six ans
mais le musicien nous avions aidé
si nous avions été en mesure de définir
une philosophie commune de l'histoire
nous n'aurions pas si le programme
commun nous aurions fusionner dans un
seul parti
s'il ya eu rupture en 1920 c'est parce
qu' on ne pouvait pas être dans le sol
dans le même parti parce qu'on ne
représentaient pas la même philosophie
politique mais comme nous continuons de
représenter les mêmes intérêts les mêmes
couches sociales les mêmes travailleurs
comme il fallait libérer ces
travailleurs de toutes les formes
d'exploitation dont ils souffrent dont
il souffre à partir de là il fallait
avoir la sagesse politique de définir
une série de contrats progressif et le
programme commun
c'est un contrat pour cinq ans ça marche
allez c'est pour dix ans ça marche pas à
se poser problème mais ça a marché
jusqu'ici
pourquoi ne pas continuer ce qui ne veut
pas dire pour autant
que nous en sommes arrivés à identifier
les socialistes et les communistes je
m'acharne a répété cette évidence cette
vérité d'analystes ce n'est pas la même
chose mais à force de travailler
ensemble
à force d'être inspiré par les mêmes
travailleurs par les mêmes ou sociale
par les mêmes exploité par les mêmes
opprimés nous sommes que leurs
représentants
je suis sûr que cette unité populaire
finira par peser sur les partis qu'ils
représentent et nous en arriverons peu à
peu en tout cas c'est mon souhait c'est
ma volonté
nous arriverons peu à peu à nous
rapprocher sur le plan des idées sur le
coin du concret toujours dans les bons
coups des deux autres questions
oui admettons que la gauche gagne
l'élection d'un gouvernement de gauche
une parti communiste comme c'est arrivé
par exemple après la libération à la
fois à des ministres au gouvernement
donc c'est siège du gouvernement et puis
en même temps que critique l'action du
gouvernement de l'extérieur
j'imagine que quand on voit ce qui se
passe en ce moment vous avez un
programme commun quand même temps
écrit-il votre conception
je pense que j'ai vécu moi les
événements de 1947 c'était membres du
gouvernement de monsieur ramadier
lorsque les communistes ont quitté le
gouvernement
ce qui ferait que sur le plan même de
l'histoire
je pense que la boucle serait
heureusement bouclé 6 et moelleux des
derniers témoins de cette scène j'ai vu
thorez j'ai vu les quatre ministres
députés quitter le gouvernement à regret
est le cinquième qui était sénateur
monsieur marc à ne pas trop savoir ce
qu'ils devaient faire puisque monsieur
amadou n'avait pas demandé une démission
de ceux qui n'avaient pas de ceux qui
n'étaient pas à l'assemblée nationale
j'ai vécu ce moment douloureux et
difficile et je souhaite pouvoir en
effet vivre le moment où
la réconciliation se fera dans le cadre
du gouvernement de la france donc je
connais bien cette histoire j'ai vécu en
effet les graves 10 centimes en vous
savez en 1947 c'était quand même à
l'époque de staline et je voudrais vous
rappeler monsieur elkabbach à cette
occasion que si j'ai trouvé les
communistes au gouvernement c'est parce
que le général de gaulle asie rémy
n'était pas tombé de nulle part c'est
une bonne idée parce que vous souhaitez
les i m c'était une très bonne idée
alors c'est pour ça que je comprends pas
très bien que les boulistes malheureux
prof
alors justement il ya par souci de
clarté je pense dans l'intérêt de
beaucoup de français et probablement
même des communistes qui vous regardent
qui nous écoutent
quelle place pourrait avoir et quelles
responsabilités pourraient avoir les
communistes dans un gouvernement non pas
du tout d'ailleurs des passagers dans la
recharge et ils sont vos jeux c'est très
laid et c'est surtout pas monsieur
monsieur marché qui vous en charger et
si ils pouvaient essais mais non le
georges marchais est un homme qui
constatera comme moi les résultats des
élections et qui n'a jamais exprimé
l'opinion que ce ne serait pas un
socialiste qui serait premier ministre
mais nous ne prétendons pas rien imposer
nous ce n'est pas notre affaire en
attendant le résultat aurait tué moi je
ne suis candidat à rien au mois de
juillet les communistes souhaité avoir
des précisions sur la composition
éventuelle d'un solide mon exclusion sur
les structures pas sur les personnes
justement sur les structures ni sur les
partis nicolas et sur le fait que payeur
georges marchais nous l'avait dit dans
cette émission aucun ministère ne
n'était tabou et la répartition des
parts à bout de toutes tailles on n'a
pas de tabou est pas une tribu perdue
qui écrit son pion d'exercer son ex
précis comme j'ai comme j'ai dû beaucoup
d'excellents livres sur ce sujet
d'ailleurs je le dis pas ça de façon
ironique qui simplement que ya pas de
tabou non on discutera mais attendons je
vous en prie le résultat des élections
alors un tandem d'anticipation avant de
passer aux primes de la majorité en tous
cas ce que je tiens à dire ici c'est que
conformément au contrat qui nous lie
l'objectif est que si nous l'emportons
les trois parties signataires du
programme commun siège temps commun au
gouvernement et assumant ensemble la
responsabilité à cerner quel sorte de
répartition j'avais une idée me répète
vous revenez là dessus j'ai pas si vous
voulez je plonge le musicien n'est pas
dans ma poche c'est parce que je voulais
dire
est-ce que je dise le président de la
république c'est monsieur giscard
d'estaing nous respectons ce et ses
compétences
nous aimerions mieux même qu'ils les
respectent davantage bon mais c'est à
lui de choisir un premier ministre
naturellement il doit le choisir dans la
majorité
dans le cas de la majorité exprimée par
le suffrage universel quand on en sera
là on étudiera la suite fait ça et je
vous en informerai et dans le parti qui
aura eu le plus grand nombre de voix
giscard d'estaing fera ce qu'il voudra
et n'a aucune obligation de choisir un
premier ministre dans le parti quel plus
grand nombre de vols et n'a aucune
obligation morale juridique
la politique c'est autre chose est ce
que vous ne craignez pas et vous le
vivez parfois dans certains cas où le pc
le parti communiste où la cgt fapt
s'appelle comme ça a été le cas y'a pas
longtemps encore aux travailleurs qui
ces risques de débordements dont on
parle que l'on dise comme c'est le cas
au moment de distribuer des exemplaires
de l'humanité pour expliquer la position
du pc par rapport à la vôtre que c'était
la vérité qui étaient dans la rue est ce
que cette cette idée de troubles et de
débordements ne vous inquiète pas
parfois c'est une hypothèse
je ne sais pas si beaucoup de françaises
et de français qui font l'honneur de
m'écouter ce soir je ne sais pas s'ils
sont nombreux à penser que le parti
socialiste et moi même nous pourrions
nous laisser porter au fil de l'eau
comme le chien crevé nous ne sommes pas
non plus le bouchon portée par les
courants si nous sommes là où nous
sommes nous les socialistes c'est parce
que ayant le sens des contrats nous
voulons les appliquer mais aussi c'est
parce que nous avons le sens de la
france et le sens de l'intérêt des
travailleurs et quelle responsabilité
serait celle d'un parti politique qui au
lendemain de la victoire de la gauche en
compromettrait les résultats dans le
seul souci d'affirmer sa personnalité ou
de poursuivre deux jeux à la fois non je
ne suppose pas une seconde que le parti
communiste puisse penser que vous venez
de
si le penser il s'exposerait ce qui est
son affaire mais il exposerait les
travailleurs de france
et là je suis sûr qu'il a conscience de
son noir s'il ne l'avait pas il faudrait
d'abord pour 2 sera pas trop tard trop
tard donc jamais trop tard dans la vie
d'un pays que deux fois la gauche a été
proche du pouvoir c'est difficile pour
la gauche de l'emporter
je vous imaginez la dose de propagande
qui doit supporter contre elle s'est
bien passé pour le savoir les avalanches
de propagande partout à qui voulait dire
ans que j'organise parce que nous lisons
la prince
non non non non vu dans une usine les
effluves de propagande la wii le
patronat j'avais le milliard du bâtonnat
les 100 milliards plus vous n'en parlez
plus nous vous ne perdez rien pour
attendre
il n'est pas trop tard non plus pour
cela parce que vous confirmerez ce que
vous avez dit muséums nature comment
vous n'y croyez pas le pilote a fait le
calcul mais en gros vous y croyez bien
mais le problème n'est pas là ni de la
maison le bruguières 100 milliards
d'anciens francs
le patronat absente va dépenser d'ici
les élections tous les milliards qu'il
faudra pour empêcher la majorité des
français détourner les morceaux dénoncer
son estime une politique économique qui
peut-être folle comme dit monsieur
chirac sur autrement dit vous allez si
je comprends bien donner des exemples
être plus précis sur le milliard les 100
milliards de centimes comme 18 heures en
audio mais c'est pas difficile
vous avez regardé les murs de paris
n'ont regardé en même temps quand vous
vous promenez vous être absorbé par
votre métier partie des regains pouvez
regarder un peu alors vous avez compris
vous savez combien ça coûte l'écran
affiche la de ces messieurs
c'est tout ça pour nous offrir le
portrait de monsieur soissons où
monsieur chirac
avouez plus souvent celui de monsieur
chirac au plus haut dans celui monsieur
chirac alors là si vous semblez arbitrer
entre deux nous aller ce soir
et bien ce soir mais je veux dire bon
aussi on a vu mon portrait seulement
général et
ils écoutent pas cher il est l'école est
généralement raid et vous avez un grand
parti avait glissé moyens il est
cohérent
malheureusement notre petit moyens s'ils
voulaient bien contribuer à accroître
nos moyens façon licite ouvert et rémy
si avec ça nous rendra lui rend service
bon mais nos deux petits moyens par
rapport à notre importance car nous
sommes soutenus par personne que par nos
militants alors ça se peut en faire la
démonstration d'ailleurs nous nous
publierons nos chiffres mais c'est un
sujet qu'il peut parler qui n'est pas
mineure pourquoi on l'abordé d'une façon
qui peut paraître plaisante mais c'est
grave
la démocratie c'est quelque chose de
sacré et si les forces de l'argent
peuvent si vous dire trafic et le
suffrage universel a buzzé delà de la
confiance des braves gens qui peuvent
pas toujours disposer des éléments de
jugement
alors c'est c'est dramatique pour la
démocratie je me fais pas leur propre
talent mais il est très possible
il est impossible qu'il se défende est
logique qu'il se défende dans un rapport
de force où les autres partenaires nous
intervient aussi à 100 dans les
entreprises soit presque à la ruse avons
les suffrages ils ont l'argent alors
naturellement et c'est qu'ils essaient
de nous prendre nos suffrages avec leur
argent mais les français sont des gens
qui sont bien formés et plus raisonnable
on croit demain monsieur vincent mi
temps 22 septembre ce premier
anniversaire du plan b si vous pouvez
que monsieur bart ou quelqu'un d'autre
avec les mêmes options que lui aurait pu
mieux faire sans aucun doute avec une
autre politique
dans le cadre de la même politique
c'était pas possible donc je ne l'accusé
pas particulièrement à monsieur bart si
donc n'était pas obligé d'être là
monsieur bah écoutez monsieur bart arif
au mois de septembre de l'année dernière
qu'est ce qui nous dit heureusement
j'arrive
parce qu'avec ce chirac une opposition
comme ça c'est tout le monde a compris
que si monsieur chirac est réservé à
chacun son marché une fois où vous
prenez des risques à chacun son marché
s'affranchir hâte
moi je pense que georges marchais quand
même quelqu'un qui représente un très
grand parti français chirac aussi
naturellement à peu près deux pme de
voix lasse le trend nombre de voix mais
c'est je pose en héritier du gaullisme
ce qui est un peu surfait tandis que
marché se présente en héritier du
gaullisme c'est indiscutable enfin on
veut pas se lancer dans ce genre de
comparaison ce que je veux dire c'est
que en fait
en fait les comme monsieur bart et on
vient notre sujet est devenu premier
ministre
tout son plaidoyer a consisté à dire
comme on gouverner mal avant moi et il
avait les chiffres d'ailleurs il est
bien obligé de les dire parce que sans
quoi alors il serait il serait
impardonnable
non la responsabilité de monsieur bart
est c'est vrai est partagé par messieurs
chirac et giscard d'estaing cette année
mais voilà il y a un an et arrive il y
développe des thèmes utile et prix vont
baisser
abc du tout alors maintenant au lieu de
dire les prix vont baisser il dit ils
vont pas monter davantage encore heureux
encore heureux
mais ça n'empêche pas que le chiffre de
1977 risque d'être aussi mauvais que le
chiffre de 1967 non mais c'est pour rire
alors l'élu chômage à l'heure actuelle
ces 6000 chômeurs par jour
le chômage on vient de battre le record
je vais dire monsieur bart en personne
vous aimez battu le record mais on n'en
était qu'à un million cent mille
maintenant c'est un million deux cent
mille c'est un échec
le commerce extérieur derniers mois
montrent que nous sommes encore dans un
grave déficit le budget est en déficit
et on le reconnaît alors que depuis dix
ans on prétendait qu'il était en
équilibre
e on vient de reconnaître que la
croissance qui était de annoncé comme de
quatre et demi pour cent n'est que de 3%
cette année
alors tout ça c'est que j'observe un
curieux phénomène sur lequel je serais
content de voir votre pire c'est que
plus ça va mal
puis monsieur bara les réjouit il
comptant alors qu'ils soient contents de
lui cela mais mécontent de sa politique
alors c'est aux français de le dire et
les français
le montre assis la gauche si la gauche
est capable dans les jours qui viennent
de dominer ses propres contrats
chiant mais cherchera raz-de-marée
justement dans les raisons qui
expliquent les difficultés de monsieur
bart il ya aussi l'environnement
international bon qui ne vit pas que ce
soit dit la seule raison mon passage où
je veux dire que quand le prix du cacao
au monde ils montrent que ce soit un
gouvernement comme celui monsieur baou
que ce soit un gouvernement
éventuellement comme celui que le ventre
mou traiter un problème très important
le problème des matières premières est
un problème qui conditionne en effet
tout politique
toute politique les matières premières
sous la pression des groupes
capitalistes et des puissances
colonialistes disons-nous valait rien on
pouvait facilement se procurer des
matières premières et est fabriqué des
produits finis et les pays industriels
occidentaux gagner un argent fou
ah et puis depuis que les pays qui
détiennent les matières premières se
sont rendus compte qu'ils avaient là un
moyen important de pression gagnent leur
vie autant que possible nature mais le
problème de matières premières se pose
en termes tout à fait différent c'est
une constante vous cela s'applique cela
s'imposera à nous comme un monsieur bah
c'est évident oui donc si vous voulez
c'est une contrainte importante
le jour de même que il ya toujours
plusieurs réponses c'est un problème
politique
c'est le même problème il ya plusieurs
réponses mais disons cinq tracés
chantois y aurait pas de politique
différent oui mais c'est un handicap
veut dire que c'est un handicap et je
personnellement je suis assez sévères à
l'égard des hommes politiques qui ne
prennent pas devant le pays leurs
responsabilités voyez vous arrivez
devant les français pour leur dire nous
allons gagner et on pourra faire tout et
n'importe quoi oh c'est vrai qu'il y
aura la fête et un air de fête et ce
sera tant mieux ce sera juste quelle
libération
mais croire que les contraintes celle
que vous venez de dire et quelques
autres le prix des matières premières la
puissance des états unis d'amérique
leur impérialisme là le poids de
l'allemagne
level 3 d le poids des sociétés
multinationales
la faible croissance et on ne peut pas
d'un seul coup multiplié par deux sans
condamner les travailleurs stakhanovisme
ou bien à abandonner le meilleur de
leurs revendications
et alors et comme ça comment alors tu
crois bien dans ces conditions
avec un environnement qui est mauvais
qui plus mauvais qu'en 72 au moment où
est dessiné pour i'm coming nous collant
pu voir dans ces conditions garantir
autant davantage nouveau alors que
l'environnement est plus mauvais parce
que nous sommes dans une société
d'inégalités et qu'un gouvernement de la
gauche entend se donner les moyens les
moyens d'une nouvelle répartition des
richesses nationales
est ce qu'il est normal que l'immense
majorité des français ceux qui
travaillaient ce qu'ils produisent
reçoivent mois dans la redistribution du
profit nationale qu'une poignée de
privilégiés
on se dit pas normal vous demande
possibles dont nous nous donnons les
moyens oui si on se donne les moyens
si on s'en donne les moyens nous
socialistes nous sommes pour les
nationalisations de l'apport du crédit
pour pouvoir orienter le crédit et nous
sommes pour la nationalisation des
grands monopoles et 9 aux industriels
subissent nous sommes pour nous sommes
pour la planification
nous sommes pour la décentralisation
nous voulons développer la capacité de
responsabilité des citoyens dans leurs
villages dans leur quartier la capacité
des travailleurs dans leur entreprise
nous voulons nous donner les moyens ces
élus mais revêt pour ça il faut que
j'explique tout le programme commun et
bien la dernière marion sans doute de
nombreuses occasions ratées restera un
1918 à mars 1918 est finalement de son
point de vue le président de la
république n'avait pas raison de ne pas
anticiper les élections législatives
écoutez moi je ne veux pas la place de
giscard d'estaing d'abord je dirais pas
que c'est bizarre mienne mais le vent
qu'il a été élu et c'est à lui le bon
environ puis c'est un homme de droite
qui est dans la avec une majorité de
droite c'est son enfant non j'ai pas du
tout ce qui est vrai c'est que depuis
maintenant deux ans et demi jusqu'à
aujourd'hui y compris aujourd'hui et
j'espère demain il est sûr que c'est la
gauche
d'après tous les sondages combes
transpire et le résultat des élections
partielles c'est la gauche qui n'en
portera donc après touche comprend assez
bien le président a public qui a dit
qu'il entend ça durera mais ça vaudra
mais quant à dire ce qui se passera au
mois de mars 1978 je tiens vous répéter
que je suis peut-être le seul
vous avez entendu monsieur part avec
beaucoup de superbes annoncé que la
victoire était assurée pour les partis
conservateurs vous avez entendu monsieur
chirac de répéter sans arrêt monsieur
giscard d'estaing moi je fais pas de
pronostic je dis non de voir il est de
parler clairement aux français et
j'espère que les français nous
comprendrons nous aidons êtes un homme
qui tenait compte du poids de vos
adversaires personnel quel est à votre
avis le plus redoutable est un monsieur
giscard d'estaing vous l'avais dit il ya
monsieur bart il ya
mais c'est chirac vous ne vous ne les
confondez pas nous non je ne peux pas
ils sont tous pareils sont pas pareils
justement leurs fins ils sont comme l
ensemble sont quand même ensemble ils
sont trés rivaux vous avez vu la
discussion entre monsieur soissons et
monsieur chirac se servant serez bercés
déjà écarté deux du front uni en réalité
du côté de l'elysée on est en train de
fabriquer une coalition contre monsieur
chirac c'est évident cela a été confirmé
par le secrétaire général du parti
républicain et n'ai pas dit ça c'est ce
que j'ai compris et vous verrez si c'est
moi qui ai bien comptés ou pas je veux
dire que la rivalité sont profondes mais
on ne peut pas oublier cependant que au
delà de la rivalité c'est comme à la
gauche
nous avons des rivalités et des
querelles mais il y a un intérêt
supérieur et eux ils ont leur intérêt
supérieur c'est le fils de société
qu'ils défendent donc je pense que
quelles que soient leurs différences ils
finiront par se re fois mais ce que je
voudrais vous dire quand je ne devrais
pas square cinq minutes et je voudrais
dire quelque chose et pas je me suis
plié aux règles de ce que je
n'appellerai pas un jeu mais de ce qui
est déjà une petite tradition d'une
émission importante
donc je réponds à vos questions et je
n'ai pas cherché à monsieur se situe
avant d'étayer ce qui se passe que vous
vivez sait jamais ce que vous deviez
faire d'une telle d'une façon qui
professionnellement et est absolument
indiscutable donc je ne peux que nous
venons captée par mes propos comme un
reproche mais mettons nous si vous
voulez bien de vendre un honneur aux
auditeurs ou téléspectateurs
les français voient cette discussion du
programme commun et la finit par des
formes est le véritable débat nous
traitions de sujets de très sérieux le
smic imaginez naturellement il faut que
j'explique suivent l'évolution de l'asie
et même avec beaucoup plus vite que le
pouvoir d'achat les autres catégories
naturellement le problème des
nationalisations très important de
savoir combien lesquels comment aider me
disais c'est très important
l'éventail de 25 oui non très important
la défense nationale est cependant aussi
nécessaire et était cette discussion
elle a un peu estompée
d'autres problèmes nous savons comment
est-ce qu'on oui mais restons paix par
nécessité mais moi je tiens à rétablir
les choses
un homme politique responsable
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il doit faire
qu'est-ce qu'il doit chercher les
questions fondamentales qui doit se
poser c'est d'abord assurément celle
qu'on a dit le pouvoir d'achat la vie
quotidienne ça il faut absolument la
solution des problèmes économiques mais
au delà
moi je vous pose avoir une je me dis le
premier devoir c'est de sauvegarder le
tissu national de sauvegarder l'unité
nationale donc de ne jamais dépasser la
limite des patients les antagonismes
politiques
même avec ses adversaires même avec ses
adversaires
cela n'ôte rien à la dureté du combat
politique
il n'y a pas de conciliation politique
entre nous mais il faut préserver le
tissu national
moi je ne me connais pas d'ennemis en
france je ne suis pas leur ennemi et
parmi tous ces mets ceux qui m'écoutent
ceux qui ont toujours voté contre ce
qu'ils ont dit ce celui là va le voir
les façons de parler à la télévision et
la trouve un peu dur quelquefois 20 ce
bien après le discutable se bat on
trouve trop dur on trouve pas assez dur
cet outil est le contraire mais mon pire
ennemi qui m'écoutent moi je suis pas
seul ennemi et je dis que le rôle du
parti socialiste c'est d'être un parti
qui assurera la permanence du tissu
national c'est la france deuxième
problème qu'on n'a pas assez traité sait
où se trouve la liberté je veux pas
faire là l'éternel liste et ses seins de
toutes les libertés encore à conquérir
je dirai à mes où se trouve la liberté
voilà les questions que je me pose je
trouve la liberté
d'abord il se trouve au niveau de ceux
qui travaillent durement de français
travailleurs immigrés ceux qui sont pris
là comme ça par les cadences dont on
vole le temps de trouver de la vie
comment arriver croyez vous qu'un autre
nettement que les socialistes pourra
parvenir à les libertés de
l'exploitation capitaliste
bon alors je me pose des problèmes vous
me direz on s'en doutait bien celui là
mais je vais plus loin je dis le comment
est ce qu'on a sur la liberté donc il
faut développer le savoir vous
développer l'éducation nationale faut
mettre le moyenne pensée de connaître il
faut libérer les gens il faut être
capable pour la liberté de dominer la
science car la science
est nécessaire mais en même temps elle
comporte des conséquences qui peuvent
être précises pour la liberté vous le
savez bien le système de police et
système des coûts des systèmes de
recherche
donc je me dis mais comment développer
la liberté dans les loisirs par la
connaissance de la culture par le goût
de la nature
puis je me dis comment est-ce qu'on peut
mois - politique responsable je parle de
ça mes amis socialistes posent dommage
que vous puissiez pas l'expliquer je
pense à vos amis politiques on savoir ce
que le silo nous parlons deux hommes un
débat politique et 7 est à ce niveau
c'est pas la faute des journalistes et
de ceux qui font chaque jour la police
je ne veux nous aimerions qu'elle se
sont joints ceux des hommes dans
l'actualité vous avez eu raison de me
poser des questions d'actualité mais les
grands problèmes sont deux sont toujours
d'actualité alors je longeais n'est pas
fini je voudrais dire moi je me
préoccupe de l'avenir je veux dire où se
trouve l'avenir tout à l'heure je me
disais où se trouve la liberté où se
trouve l'avenir
bon mais à l'avenir je me dis bon
naturellement va dire la jeunesse sont
bien là mais il faut qu'ils aient déjà
un pays comme la france il a besoin de
nombreux jeunes on peut pas on a besoin
d'eux une politique démographique en a
besoin d'une politique de la natalité
on a besoin de constituer le corps
physique de la france et le corps
physique de la france c'est non
seulement les hommes les femmes qui vit
sur son sol c'est sa nature il faut que
l'homme domine la nature mais qu'il
préserve ses équilibres
ça ce sont les problèmes physiques mais
aussi les problèmes spirituels
il faut se préoccuper de tous les moyens
que calum de parvenir à la connaissance
c'est à dire que je me pose moi comme en
politique tous les jours ces problèmes
j'en parle à mes meilleures amies dont
quelques uns sont dans cette salle
d'autres sont un inconnu et nous sommes
des amis nous à la tête du parti
socialiste sont pas seulement des
camarades nous sommes des amis on a nos
difficultés
nous sommes des amis qu'est ce que sait
où se trouve la liberté qu'est ce que
c'est où se trouve l'avenir où se trouve
la la responsabilité de l'homme
à quoi aspire thil ont dieu tu n'es pas
mort c'est un thème général je ne fais
pas de déclarations de caractère
personnel je n'ai pas entretenir les
français des questions personnelles que
je me pose mais mais mais dieu a
représenté pour toute la société
chrétienne et combien d'autres
une capacité de sublimer de transposer
de transférer d'avoir une fois tant elle
dans les vieilles monarchie
de droit divin qui se croyait de droit
divin leroy la hiérarchie les traditions
et puis d'autres sont devenus fous
c'était la recherche du sens la
recherche de la race tous ont cherché
mais voyez-vous pas que l' aventure de
la science de l'aventuré de la recherche
que l'accomplissement des équilibres
naturels que la conquête de l'espace que
la conquête de l'espace intérieur
ce ne soit pas un devoir politique c'est
à dire de ne rien faire qui puisse
empêcher qui fut supprimée alors moi je
me pose ces problèmes tous les jours
alors je me dis sur le plan de la
politique quotidienne
ben il faut employer les moyens tant
qu'on aura un état fabriqué comme il est
aujourd'hui plus tu veux dire avec ceux
qui le gouvernent
parce qu'ils ont rien changé ils ont
échoué qui représente en réalité une
formidable puissance à la tête de petit
gros d'hommes doté de toute compétence
paraît-il qu'ils connaissent à fond leur
dossier mais qui veulent faire le
bonheur des français sans demander
l'avis des français véritablement sans
casser la mécanique d'un état centralisé
sang permettront plus petit village sans
permettre à la plus petite entreprise de
vivre en fabriquant elle même son destin
en avance en réfléchissant en se
concertant tant qu'on en sera pâle à
cette mécanique la inversée à savoir que
si la france a assuré sa grandeur parce
nullité c'était nécessaire au moment des
jacobins
c'était nécessaire à la fin de la
monarchie la france pouvait éclater nous
avons deux siècles depuis ce depuis
cette époque là l'unité de la france
elle sera assurée par le respect de ses
différences par le respect de ces
cultures et par la capacité individuelle
et de chaque petit groupe de s'affirmer
en tant que tel voilà les vrais
problèmes
quand je dis voilà les vrais problèmes
ça ne veut pas dire pour ça que ce que
nous ce que nous avons dit que l'air la
recherche approfondie du programme
commun ne soit pas capital aussi mais il
ne faudrait pas que ce voile qui occupe
depuis l'été la discussion publique
obscurcissent les réalités de l'avenir
il s'agit de construire pas simplement
la france il s'agit de certes que
l'homme vous dire la femme l'homme à
tout âge quel qu'il soit soit plus
ebr est ce que vous voyez qu'on est
libre quand on est parfois mal monsieur
mi temps on voit bien apparaître les
différents aspects de votre personnalité
genre que l'on retrouve dans le livre
que j'ai publié en ce moment politique
où on retrouve depuis 40 ans tout ce que
vous avez pu dire ou écrire les
personnalités qui qui est qui se
penchera méditation philosophique
historique et en même temps l'homme
politique vous l'avez montré à travers
l'émission mais nous sommes nous lier à
ski et le quotidien et l'actualité
politique qu'est ce que vous pensez qu
avant de développer ses réflexions
philosophiques à nouveau vous allez
pouvoir vous entendre avec vos alliés
disons d'ici à la fin de la semaine
la semaine prochaine vous avez parlé là
du livre que vient d'être publié et sous
la responsabilité de l'éditeur et qui en
effet offre toute une eux tout seuls on
dirait un compte rendu de nos activités
politiques qui marie ses contradicteurs
lente évolution est surtout avec seule
unité cavale vous serez convaincu
d'envoi leurs élus mais je ne suis pas
ici et je vous remercie d'avoir fait
discrètement pour faire quelques
publicités que ce soit sur ce livre je
ne demande absolument pas bénéficié du
statut de monsieur giscard d'estaing
mais n'inquiétait pas vous l'aurez assez
facilement je suis sûr je suis pas non
mais ma question mais les politiques
parce que nous terminions régionaux
raffiné en disant simplement que je suis
incapable de faire un pronostic que si
nos partenaires veulent bien admettre
tout le programme commun rien que le
programme commun
cela sera signé demain matin si on nous
posait des problèmes nouveaux
raisonnable cela durera plus longtemps
en s'entendant si on nous pose encore
des problèmes insolubles à savoir ce
deuxième programme commun avant d'avoir
fait le premier cela n'aboutira pas le
parti socialiste et chacun ici l'a senti
fera tout et je ferai tout pour que
l'union de la gauche l'emporté pour
l'emporter il faut qu'elle se réalise
elle même mais nous ne ferons pas le
contraire de ce en quoi nous croyons aux
autres
le premier pain vous autres de ces
deux-là nous de faire des pas à eux d'en
faire mais ne me contre faire ni
contredire la vérité fondamentale qui
est la nôtre
le programme commun tel que nous l'avons
signé était que nous l'avons proposé à
la femme de faire cela en discutant
d'actualisation puisque l'on revient à
72 cents la haine signer monsieur
elkabbach vous méritez sur les rails du
début de notre conversation
ces conflits ne vous répond c'est vous
qui vous est demandé de vous répondre et
moi j'ai dit oui les petites minutes
c'est ce que j'ai fait ce que je veux
dire c'est que sur le plan place et je
pense que l'actualisation était
nécessaire dans ce ne serait que pour
ajuster les propositions du programme
commun à l'évolution de la vie
économique des prix du chômage et le
reste j'ai déjà dit qu'il fallait aussi
actualiser le programme commun pour
répondre aux questions nouvelles qui
s'étaient posés depuis 1972 parce que
l'histoire a couru voilà ce que j'ai dit
et ses réponses là je suis prêt et nous
sommes prêts à les apporter dans le
meilleur esprit d'amitié et de travail à
nos partenaires communistes et radicaux
de gauche merci la prochaine émission de
cartes sur table le mercredi 26 octobre
à bientôt
[Musique]